the world's richest man is now in
control of one of its most influential
communication platforms let that sink in
after a month's long will he won't he
Saga Elon Musk buying Twitter for 44
billion dollars let the good times roll
he tweeted musk wasted no time making
his Mark even before this takeover had
been officially announced the chief
executive and Chief Financial Officer
was shuttled from the building behind me
and told not to return it is a sign of
just how fundamentally he plans to
change things here
and among his remaining staff mixed
feelings I'm half excited
half scared like I'm excited for you
know the new leadership and obviously
Twitter I struggle to make money
um with good monetization strategies so
I think I'm excited to see what he will
turn Twitter into but I'm stressed about
you know all the chaos it's gonna bring
in and what does it mean for our
day-to-day work and like
um
what does it mean for work balance what
does it mean for some people getting
laid off chaos it's fair to say is
expected musk believes more free speech
in his own words is what's needed on
Twitter that could involve reinstating
the account of former president Donald
Trump but for now musk says there's no
movement on that front Twitter will be
forming a Content moderation council
with widely diverse viewpoints he wrote
no major content decisions or account
reinstatements will happen before that
Council convenes he says he wants half
the world on his website but some are
unconvinced he's fascinating he's uh you
know infuriating he's brilliant
um but I'm not sure that I want um him
in control of you know a fairly large
platform and Twitter's not the biggest
platform in social media in the world is
probably at its it's uh maybe it's best
days are behind it but still the fact
that one man controls it I think is uh
you know as a matter for concern for all
of us
so it's even harder to predict Martha
kellner's Sky News San Francisco